What we've been looking at for the last few examples is vertex form. Vertex
form indicates the vertex of a parabola, h and k. For parabolas that open up
and down, the h value is the opposite sign of the one in the binomial, and the
k value is the one on the end. Remember we can always find the x coordinate of
this vertex by setting the binomial equal to zero. And if we look at the number
in front of the squared term, we can determine whether or not the parabola
opens up, or if the parabola opens down. If the a value is positive or greater
than 0, the parabola opens up. And if the a value is negative, or less than 0,
then the parabola must open down. Horizontal parabolas are a little bit more
tricky. These parabolas start with x equals and either open to the right or to
the left. We find the vertex by looking at h and k. Notice here that h is added
on the end or subtracted in some cases. And k is the number inside the
binomial. Notice that h is now the number on the end, where k is the number in
the binomial. We can find the y coordinate of the vertex by setting this
binomial equal to zero. The x coordinate of the vertex, for horizontal
parabolas, will just be the number, added or subtracted, on the end. And
finally, if the a value was greater than 0 or positive, we know the graph opens
to the right. Whereas if the a value is less than 0, or negative, then our
graph opens to the left.